hey everyone welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from Google cloud we've
been hosting these webinars every
Tuesday this February my name is Kurt
Enzi and I am a Google cloud specialist
that specializes in our productivity and
collaboration tools this afternoon I'm
going to be spending some time talking
with you about different tips and tricks
to get the most out of G suite you can
ask questions any time using the
platform and we have Googlers standing
on by to help answer them sound good all
right mm-hmm
so the first stop in our tour today
we're gonna be talking about Gmail as
you are all aware Gmail is a pretty good
application and you're probably pretty
familiar with how to use it but the
first thing I'm gonna show you is the
search feature so I think you all are
familiar with the fact that you can type
in a search term or you can type in an
email and spend time looking through all
of those but what I want to do is sort
of up level your ability to do Google
searches so we're gonna be working in a
domain today called on-site it and in
this domain I've subscribed to a lot of
rock climbing and mountaineering
different newsletters so let's say we're
gonna look for a term called belay we've
been able to pull up all these different
emails that have balay associated with
them but I need to do a little bit more
searching I want to dig in a little bit
on this if we come over here this is
what we call our advanced search options
we can click down into advanced search
and we see a whole nother interface of
ways to get more granular and the type
of searching that we're doing first
thing that we'll see is we can choose
the location that we're going to be
doing our search we can choose all mail
inbox in this case I'm going to look for
unread mail we have the ability to add a
from field that will tell us who sent
the email we have the ability to search
by who the email was sent to as well as
keywords in the subject and also
keywords anywhere in the email in this
case we brought belay over from our
original search you can also specify
words that you don't want to be included
in the
so for example we don't want to talk
about ice climbing today so we're gonna
remove that and then you have options to
determine if there is attachments or if
there are chats available as well as
size and date so we'll click through
this search and we've gone from 23
different emails down to 3 which is much
more manageable gives you the ability to
look through and and and use your emails
more effectively now that's pretty cool
but I think that many of you are
probably want to want to gonna want to
be what we call power users of Gmail
right so here's what I would recommend
that you do if you'd like to be a Gmail
power user open up and go to google.com
and search for the term Gmail search
operators the first hit is a help
article from our Gmail help pages
bookmark this and then do your best to
try and memorize these there's a whole
long list of search operators that you
can use within Gmail to try and do more
granular searches so for example if we
come back to our inbox let's say we want
to see any emails that are unread that
have been sent before January 1st of
this year and has an attachment just
with a simple set of search operators
we're able to get very specific on the
types of emails that were pulling up to
search for which gives you a lot of
power in using Gmail awesome so we've
learned a little bit about advanced
search we've learned a little bit about
search operators but let's think of
another way that we can get organized
and for that I want to share with you
some information about labels a label is
something that you can be that can be
approximated as a folder but with some
key differences essentially a label in
Gmail is a different view of your mail
environment that allows you to see
different sets of data inbox starred
sent mail and drafts those are all
examples of
default labels but we have the ability
to create our own labels so if you
notice over here we've got a lot of
messages coming from rock and ice
magazine and since my boss doesn't
really like it when I'm looking at rock
climbing magazines on the job we're
gonna filter these out we're gonna label
them so that they're out of our way so
we'll create a new label
and we're going to call this rock and
ice if you notice here we can nest this
label underneath of another one we could
put it under newsletters personal
anything we want but just for the sake
of ease we're gonna create its own
top-level label and notice now over here
on the right is a label called rock and
ice if we click on it right now
there's no conversations in here we
haven't labeled anything nothing really
has happened yet so we'll come back to
our top-level
inbox and there's a couple of different
ways now that we can interact with this
label the first would be to take a
message and drag it and drop it over
into our label that message has now been
archived and it has the label rock and
ice applied to it so if we click in
there here's our rock and ice we can
also go the other direction so let's say
we can select a few of these and now we
want to label these with rock and ice
but not archive them we take rock and
ice from our label set we drop it on top
and now they're all labeled rock and ice
the interesting thing about these now if
you click on to one of these into one of
these emails you can see up at the top
that it has the label rock and ice and
it also has the label in box because it
lives in both of those worlds to make
labels even more useful we can actually
adjust the color this is gonna help it
stand out and make it easier for you to
see so in this case we'll turn this
label into bright orange there it is
orange up there it's orange down here
and if we come back into our inbox here
are all the rock and ice labeled items
that's all well and good you know I've
taught you how to create a label how to
change the color how to drag and drop
things but you probably don't want to
spend
your entire day dragging and dropping
e-mails back and forth right well good
news we're gonna use something called a
filter to try and help automate this
process a filter is going to start at
the same place that the advanced search
does and in this case we're gonna filter
out the emails that have the words
recognized so just the words recognized
and nothing else so we're gonna put in a
quotation will type rock and ice close
quotation this is going to ensure that
we're looking for just that phrase and
not for any any email that has the word
Rock or any email that has the word ice
because that could complicate things a
bit what we'll do from here before I
create the filter is I actually just go
through with the search and take a look
and see to make sure that I'm not
picking up anything unusual everything
looks good so we'll come back in and
we're going to create a filter with this
search now that we're in the filter
options here there's a lot of things
that we can do with it we can skip the
inbox which we'll do in this case you
can mark it as red so that you don't
even have to realize that it came in I
want to read it at some point so I'll
leave it you can star it you can apply
the label that's what we're gonna do
today we're going to apply the label
rock and ice then you could do things
like forward it delete it send it to
spam make sure it's always marked
important all kinds of good stuff there
and you would hit create the filter now
once we hit create filter any new email
that matches this search will apply
these rules it will skip the inbox it
it'll apply the label rock and ice and
it'll be good to go but what about all
these existing ones that are already
there I can just simply check this box
right here also apply filter to matching
conversations we create the filter and
now all of those are filtered out into
rock and ice nice and easy a'right gives
you an automatic way to manage your
inbox
to organize your labels too and we've
also learned a little bit about how to
do some searching
awesome well the next thing that we want
to do now that we've talked about ways
that you can sort of automatically
organize your emails I like to spend
time with our customers telling them
about how to visually organize your
inbox there's a lot of different ways to
do that the first thing that I like to
show people is turning on and off
conversation view I've been a gmail user
for since it was in beta many many years
ago so I love conversation view but it's
what I would call a polarizing setting
right either you love it or you hate it
and I want to give you the ability to
turn it on and off depending on what
suits you a conversation in Google just
for those of you that may not be aware
is essentially where we take messages
that are related together usually by
subject line and we bundle them together
so here at the top is an example of a
conversation might be a little confusing
because I had the conversation with
myself for demonstration purposes but we
can click into here and we can see that
there are three different messages first
is the message that I sent then reply
and then another reply there if you want
to debug these so that they don't exist
together you simply come into your
settings and you go into settings again
now at the top you'll notice there are a
number of tabs for your settings this
one's going to live in the general area
about a third of the way down is
conversation view you turn conversation
view off and then this is key when
you're changing your settings in Gmail
make sure that you save changes awesome
so now you can see that that
conversation bundle has been d bundled
and now it's two separate emails so if
you're not a fan of conversation view
you're welcome I just totally changed
your life the next thing that I like to
show customers is something called the
preview pane so a lot of people have
lived in other mail clients where they
have the ability to see their inbox on
one side and a preview of the email on
the other side so we can do that in
Gmail too if we come to settings we're
going to go to a new tab now and this
tab is called labs
Labs are experimental features that you
can enable for Gmail these labs are
gonna be controlled by your
administrator so not all of them that
I'm showing you here may be available
but that's gonna be up to your admin to
figure out there's a lot of really great
ones in here can responses custom
keyboard shortcuts but the one that I
want to show you is the preview pane
again click on enable don't forget to
save your changes and it's gonna refresh
our inbox for us looks the same right
now but you notice we have this new
button up here this is where we control
our preview so we can choose what type
of split we want to use I tend to like
the vertical split and now we have the
ability to preview these messages
without losing our inbox you can simply
click on your email and there it is on
the right side panel pretty good stuff
right the last thing that I like to show
people in terms of organizing your
physically organizing your inbox is what
I call a Priority Inbox
so if we come back to our settings
within Inbox
there are there's something called an
inbox type default inbox type is simply
where your inbox will organize things in
chronological order the most recent
email that comes in sits on top but
there's other ways that you can do that
you can do important first where
important emails surfaced to the top you
can do unread first where any emails
that you haven't read yet surface to the
top start first similarly anything that
has a star I like to do what's called
the Priority Inbox this is how I use my
personal Gmail and how I use my my work
G suite account Priority Inbox lets you
have multiple sections as well as the
ability to change and and prioritize
those as needed
so first we'll come important and unread
then we'll come starred we can even add
labels in here too so we're gonna add a
section if we come into more options
here's our rock and ice and then
everything else again we'll save our
changes
and notice that things have changed a
little bit up here is important unread a
quick note about importance importance
is a concept in Gmail that is a learning
algorithm as you mark things important
or not important based off of things
like who sent the email will the content
of the email who's receiving the email
it will automatically determine what
youth what you might think is important
so you can train your algorithm by
marking things on and off and it'll get
better over time here down is down here
is what we have for starred then we've
got our rock and ice and you can
collapse these as needed and here is
everything else the priority inbox is my
favorite way to manage my inbox it gives
me the ability to surface the things
that are important on red first then I
use stars as some similar to a to-do
list and then everything else is stuff
that I don't think it was really that
important anymore excellent now a couple
more things to show you in Gmail the
first one is actually my favorite
setting in Gmail
it's called undo send let's say we're
going to compose a message and we're
sending a message to Albert Einstein
because I work with him and we're gonna
say please review this information I'm
really excited I'm sending it Albert
Einstein some info so I'm gonna say hi
Bert please take a look below and give
me your thoughts but what happens when I
get too excited and I accidentally just
send it without finishing the email have
you guys ever done that it hit Send and
uh-oh what do I do
I've actually got this undo send button
right here where I can click undo and I
get my email back I have the ability to
finish it slowed down a little bit
proofread it and then I can send it out
again in order to turn on undo send you
come into settings under the general tab
about four or five down we've got undo
send you enable that and you get to
choose the cancellation period
I choose 30 seconds because sometimes I
get a little bit can
and don't realize that I messed it up
but this is one of my favorite favorite
settings and it has saved me more times
than I can count the last thing that I'm
going to show you about Gmail before we
move on is what we call Gmail shortcuts
so like I said a lot of you probably
want to be Gmail power users if you hit
shift and question mark it's gonna pull
up all the different shortcuts that you
can use to interact with the Gmail
interface the idea behind this is the
less time you spend grabbing for your
mouse and looking around and things like
that the less context switching that you
do the faster you're gonna be at
composing emails at being productive
right so there's a lot of them there
you'll learn them over time but for
example if we want to take a look at our
starred messages we can simply type G s
and it will automatically pull up our
starred messages if we want to look at
our labels we can type G L and choose
our rock and ice label and here we are
if we want to go back to our inbox we
can type G and I there's our inbox and
then if you wanted to compose a new
message you simply type D and there does
it automatically brings up a new message
for you again the idea is we're going to
take seconds off of each task so that
those seconds add up to minutes
throughout the week which adds up to
hours throughout the months so on and so
forth awesome so to review in Gmail
we've learned a little bit about
searching both advanced as well as super
advanced with the search operators we've
learned about labels we've learned about
filtering and then we've learned about
how to visually organize your inbox in
different ways but I don't know about
you my life is controlled by my calendar
not by my inbox so if it doesn't exist
on my calendar it's not real it's not in
my head so let's move over to calendar
and look at some of the cool things we
can do here this right here is actually
called the waffle so you select the
waffle and this gives you the
opportunity to choose a new application
for those of you that are G sweet
customers or use Gmail in your personal
life you've probably seen the new Gmail
interface or I'm sorry the new calendar
interface but if you haven't that's
alright
welcome to the new calendar interface
will start the in here the same place
that we started in Gmail and that's
searching you can again search by terms
but let's take a look at the advanced
search options this gives you a lot of
really good ways to look through your
events that are much more powerful so we
can look at different calendars we can
type in keywords we can select
organizers or participants so we can
choose location or room we can exclude
keywords and then also the dates again
the idea is to make it easy for you to
find what you're looking for now the
next thing I'm going to show you is
pretty interesting I'm sure you're all
aware of how to view a calendar of your
coworker you simply come into here you
can type in your co-workers name select
it now we can see that person's calendar
overlaid with mine but there's something
called public calendars that are pretty
interesting if you click on the plus and
add other calendars you can browse
calendars of interests this is going to
give us a number of religious and
regional holidays a very long list of
different regional holidays so if you're
working with a particular region very
frequently you can be up to date on
their holidays if you're a sports fan it
also has public sports calendars I used
to live in Chicago so we can come in to
hockey take a look at the NHL select the
Blackhawks and we've added that calendar
now I can scroll down and I can see here
are all the black box events pretty cool
right awesome the next thing that I'd
like to show you is what's called
appointment slots imagine tomorrow I'm
gonna be meeting with a large number of
customers right six seven eight
customers and instead of emailing each
one individually and trying to
coordinate all the different times that
are possible for me to be with them I'm
going to create an appointment slot send
everybody one link and let them
determine when there's availability so
to do that we're going to drag and drop
we'll do our appointments tomorrow from
8:00 to noon
we're gonna call this meetings with Kurt
and up here we choose appointment slots
the next thing that we have to do is
determine what our duration is going to
be we're gonna make 30-second 30-minute
meetings and we'll save this now instead
of me having to coordinate with all
these people I can simply click on this
calendars appointment page copy the link
and then send that link to a customer if
we were to this is another environment
that I have if we were to put this in
and give it to the customer it's
actually going to show a calendar
interface where it overlays their
calendar with all of these open
appointments and in order for that
person to schedule a meeting with me
they simply have to click on one fill
out the information and save it that
appointments been booked and if we go
and look back at my original calendar we
should have a new appointment right here
that we just scheduled right a really
simple and easy way for you to minimize
the amount of time that you're doing
coordinating and shuffling times and all
that just simply with calendar
appointments next couple of things I
want to show you are small but but
powerful things one is within the new
calendar you have the ability to restore
deleted events in a very easy way let's
say I've got a proposal meeting tomorrow
and I accidentally delete it thinking it
was something else not a problem
you simply come up to the settings into
trash and here I can select and restore
this event and if we come back in just a
moment it should be restored nice and
simple the next one is what I call
invisible events imagine on Thursday
morning I'm gonna go rock climbing for
the morning instead of coming into the
office I don't want my boss to know that
I'm out rock climbing but I also don't
want me to see that do not schedule
block right so we'll call this rock
climbing and we're gonna come into more
options if I mark it as private it'll
still show up on my calendar as an event
but no but nobody can see the details
but if I mark it as private and I change
my status to free then it won't show up
on anybody else's calendar and I'll be
the only one that can see it effectively
making it an invisible event pretty
pretty pretty good stuff there last two
things are new settings in calendar that
I think are worth taking note of on the
left here we have our time for our
schedule you have the ability to have a
second time zone displayed so if we come
into our settings under time zones you
can display a second time zone I'm
frequently working with Mountain View
where Google's headquarters is so I'm
gonna have that be my second time zone
now we come back and automatically as
I'm scheduling things as I'm building
out my eight my calendar for the week I
can easily see what the time is in
Mountain View and then another thing
that's really great is what's called
working hours so I'm very protective of
my work-life balance so within our
settings I've set working hours such
that when people try to invite me from
Monday through Friday outside of the
hours from 9:00 to 6:00 p.m.
they'll actually receive a warning and
that warning will say are you sure you
want to schedule it at this time this is
outside of Kurt's working hours pretty
pretty good stuff some of you may not
have the the luxury of being able to
schedule those working hours but if you
do I highly recommend it although what I
found is that it hasn't really kept
anybody from scheduling outside of those
hours anyway oh well last thing in
Google Calendar similar to how we have
shortcuts in Gmail we have a large
number of shortcuts in Google Calendar
and so with this the the press of a
button you can do things like change the
view if we would rather see a day view
versus a week view versus a month view
you also have a custom view which in
this case I've set to 3 days and you can
also select on the side and choose your
own custom view if I wanted to do a four
day view you can select on this calendar
the four day view and then it'll May
that as you scroll through different
time periods excellent we've talked a
lot about calendar we talked about Gmail
let's spend a few minutes in Google
Drive and Doc's so within Google Drive
there's a couple of interesting things
to show you again we have an advanced
search feature which gives you a lot of
really robust ways to search through
your data we the next thing is a
extension that I think everybody should
should be using it's called the office
editing for docs extension if you search
for that and pull it up in Chrome this
gives you the ability to edit office
docs in their native format while in
Google really highly recommend it
because we recognize here at Google that
oftentimes you're not going to be
working with somebody else
in Google's environment and so you need
to have the ability to edit those
documents if we take a look at a Google
if we take a look at a document that is
not a Google formatted document you also
have the ability to do versioning as
well so within a Google Doc I'm sure
you're aware you can click on revision
history and see every change that you've
made you can do something similar to
that with a within Google Drive so you
select this is a Word document here if
you select that and you click on View
details you come into details down here
in the bottom right gives you the
ability to manage versions we can see
all the different versions that we've
had I edited it at 1111 and you can see
all the different versions all the way
back to when it was created in 2014 this
is an old one you can upload new
versions you can also download or delete
particular versions something that a lot
of people don't recognize when they're
dealing with other formatted types
within Google Drive as well there's
something called quick access so quick
access is a setting that you can turn on
under suggestions which will actually
take into account when you'll ask to
open the
cuman what things are on your schedule
and will allow you to and will
automatically surface the things that it
thinks you're gonna work on most often
which is a great feature as well
excellent we've talked a little bit
about versioning we've talked a little
bit Microsoft documents and Drive next
let's step into a Google sheet and show
you some of the really cool things that
are coming out for that so if we come
into our folder here I have a new sheet
it's called Black Friday week sales data
so it's from this past Black Friday and
what I want to do is well first of all
it's a little bit hard to see there's
you know it's not formatted well so
let's do a little bit of quick
formatting to make it easier to see the
first thing that we're gonna do will
select everything if we go into format
alternating colors this is a really
quick and easy way to just add some
color to the document and make it easier
to read we can also do something called
freezing so if we go into view we freeze
our first row and now as we scroll down
the title page the title row stays with
it to make it easier to see what all
these numbers are that's all pretty
awesome but what I really want to do is
get some insight from this data we have
this new feature called Explorer the
Explorer feature will give us the
ability to do some really interesting
things it's powered by some some awesome
AI and the first thing you'll notice is
that it gives us an automatic suggestion
for a pivot table and then in this case
the pivot table displays average of unit
price for each item really useful if you
had to build that pivot table on your
own might take you some time
you can simply just click and add that
in it also does some initial analysis in
this case cost of goods versus profit
and you can scroll through and see which
ones you find interesting and then in
order to add it you simply click insert
chart and there we go
with the click of a button we've got a
count of items graph here pretty useful
but
let's say we want even more data we want
to learn even more about it if we come
to back to our explore function we can
actually ask natural language questions
of this feature and get answers back so
let's say we want to know what item has
the highest profit margin it actually
understands that question as top item by
profit margin which in this case was the
watch with a profit margin of zero point
six and we can click in even further and
see the query that it used to figure
that out which I'm pretty decent with
Google sheets but would've taken me
quite a while to figure that out awesome
another really interesting thing about
Google sheets is you have the ability to
turn on notifications in the event that
somebody edits the document so if we
come into Tools notification rules you
can choose notify me at my email address
any time changes are made and you can do
it either at a daily digest digest or
email right away we click Save and now
anytime somebody adds data to this I'll
be able to recognize it and see the new
data pretty good stuff so let's review
all that we've seen today we've seen
quite a bit we've talked about Gmail
we've talked about how to search and
organize your inbox we've talked about
calendar and some of the cool tricks
with new calendar in order to manage
your days and times especially
appointment slots we've talked about
Google Drive and how to work with some
files that aren't Google file types in
Google Drive both through versioning as
well as through the extension and then
we've talked a little bit about Google
sheets and some of the excellent new
features that are coming into Google
sheets around explore and formatting and
things along those lines so that's so
everything that I wanted to show you for
this demo today we're gonna take some
live questions so stay tuned for that
and we'll be back in less than a minute
you
all right welcome back everyone thanks
for sticking with us we're gonna go
through a couple of questions that came
up before I get started on those we
noticed that quite a few of the
questions that came in were about
product roadmap I just want to give you
all a little bit of a heads up if you
are asking about product roadmap and
you're a current customer please feel
free to reach out to your Google Account
Manager and they can help you walk
through the product roadmap for both G
suite and Google Cloud if you're a
prospective customer and you're
interested in learning more about our
product note roadmap please go and visit
the Google Google cloud blog where we'll
make all public announcements awesome so
we've got five questions here that we
can potentially address today the first
is whether the company is the ultimate
owner of data for every user in G suite
that's absolutely correct when you're
putting your data into G suite Google
identifies that you're the owner of that
data and Google is what's called a data
processor meaning that at any time you
have the ability to remove that data
from Google we don't use that data for
advertisements we don't use that data
for improving our products we don't use
that data for selling we don't do
anything with it it's your data but
thanks for asking
regarding Google vault if I enable vault
for an organization and set the
retention period to undefined if an
employee leaves the company and I delete
his or her account can i browse an
export a specific file of this user so
this is an interesting question for
undefined I think you probably meant
indefinite which means you would keep
that data forever but there's a there's
a particular caveat here when you're
using Google vault and you have a user
that stored data there whether it's in a
legal hold or whether it's in just the
normal retention period if you delete
that user that data is no longer around
right and so what you want to do there's
a couple of different options if you're
going to be deleting a user and you want
to save that data I would recommend
doing the export prior to deleting the
user there are a couple other options
and this is a an important part of the
the prop the platform for you please
reach out to your Google account man
we can talk a little bit more about the
details all right can we put Google
Drive files Google Drive documents into
labels instead of putting them in
folders in that case what happens if the
folders are shared so at this point
Google Drive the files that we store in
Google Drive have limited metadata you
have the ability to look at the metadata
that is there and add a small
description but the concept of labels
don't actually exist at this point in
Google Drive so if that's something that
you're looking for in terms of
functionality we have a number of
third-party third-party providers that
can add that type of functionality one
would be power tools another would be a
Oh Docs
those are both third party platforms
that are built on top of Google Drive
that help you with your sort of content
management CMS type of of needs can
people book appointments with calendar
appointments if they don't have a Google
account they can book appointments with
calendar appointment slots the
difference being is that it's not going
to show them an example of their
calendar that would just give them the
opportunity to book the slot and then
they would have to manage the calendar
appointment in their own calendar
finally the ever-popular question can we
turn off conversation mode on mobile or
iOS and at this point it is not possible
unfortunately you're stuck with conver
conversation mode in your mobile device
unless of course you choose to use the
native iOS mail application in which
case you would need to have access from
your administrator to do IMAP mapping
for your gmail account
excellent those are all the questions
that we've got for you today thank you
very much for joining us please be sure
to tune in next week for more
information about Google cloud
appreciate everybody's time